Continental Tire Coaches Corner
coach Luke Walton join us Continental
Tire proud to be the exclusive tire the
Dan Patrick show no matter where you
drive or what you drive Continental
designs tires for what you do for more
information visit Continental Tire
dot-com Continental Tire for what you do
he is the head coach of the Lakers he's
Luke Walton back on the program
we were wondering over/under how many
Grateful Dead concerts you went to with
your dad oh I probably 9 or 10 okay
I mean I thought I might even if I would
know while I was pretty uh let me
rephrase that 9 or 10 now I can remember
II they used to take us to a bunch when
we were little not like that but we
heard little kids that I don't really
recall but once we got a little bit
older I remember going to some of the
shows with with him
did you understand why your dad loved
the Grateful Dead so much no idea quiet
as a kid I had no idea what my dad did
mostly it has it not saw gotten older I
really started to appreciate what he he
was all about you know what it was like
and how cool was growing up with him
when did you realize how famous your dad
was um probably probably in junior high
high school and I always remember being
a kid and people stopped and asked for
pictures that I just didn't really I
didn't really get it until you know I
got a little older and I got really into
basketball myself it was playing in
camps and then you know people would
really everywhere I go people would tell
me you have any idea how great your dad
was I'd be like no he's funny dude I was
telling a story that I gave him a ride
one time from New Jersey to New York
into the city and I had a Jetta and he
sat in the front seat and sang at the
top of his lungs Bob Dylan songs the
entire trip from the
Jerzy NBA entertainment to the city and
I tried to turn the volume up as loud as
I could to drown out your dad I couldn't
do it yeah he was singing at the top of
his lungs and not singing well now he's
a terrible singer which is unfortunate
because his father and my uncle boat you
know they both got some face and their
voice and they could taken uh you know
they can they can carry a song for sure
but he's he's awful and he loved he
loves the thing but to his credit he's
coming if he loves life so as bad as he
is a thing and he enjoys it he'll he'll
break into Bob Dylan quotes whenever he
feels appropriate a meal young same way
but he's a good man he's Luke Walton the
Lakers head coach they went 26 and 56
this year what was management's game
plan once you're not playoff eligible
you know to put on well at first the the
biggest the biggest thing or gameplay
was getting you know trying to set a
foundation for what we need to do where
we're going to be you know next year in
a year after that and and then obviously
we're trying to win as many games as
possible now once we got to a place
where the playoffs weren't gonna be a
realistic thing then it was it was about
setting that foundation still but also
at the same time getting you know
getting our young guys we have five or
six guys under the age of like 24 that
are big part a big part of what we're
doing so we had to get them as much
experience as possible let them feel
what it's like to be in a two-point game
down the stretch draw and draw plays for
guys uh you know what you need you need
to get a stop in an in a scorer and so
it was really about getting them as much
experience as we could but still holding
them to a standard of play as far as the
style of play and and the way we want to
play each and every night Mark Cuban
came out and said that the Mavs
tanked that he makes no excuses for it
that he played young guys but he was
trying to improve their draft status
their ping-pong opportunities there is
there anything wrong with that because
you you had to rest players whether it
was your decision or not but Luol Deng
or Mozgov and you're sitting down guys
that may have given me a better chance
you do get the young guys some playing
time but is is there it it feels like
it's the current culture Luke that once
you get there that this is what we need
to do yeah and there's there I wants it
there's nothing wrong with it it's
obviously not what's meant what would
the whole lottery set up for what the
NBA is about I totally understand the
the idea behind it I mean you're talking
about the possibility of you know
totally changing the future of your fan
franchise with certain draft dicks for
us our philosophy has been the Lakers
we've we've lost way too much over the
past three or four seasons and you know
winning isn't something that you know
just happens you have to develop it as a
skill just like anything else in the
game you have to learn how when you have
to know what it feels like to win and
you know myself
talking with magic and Rob down the
stretch you know we all believe like
when you do things the right way to good
things are going to have going to happen
for you and half of our team so we
wanted we want our young guys to feel
what it was like to win now obviously if
you lose when you're in that type of
situation it doesn't hurt as bad because
you know there's there's a positive side
to the Lottery's but we wanted our young
guys out there playing as hard as they
could trying to win every game that
they're you know every time they're on
the court just to help build that that
winning culture back up that we haven't
had here in a few years what if you
don't agree with the front office on who
you should take a draft pick whether
it's this number to pick or at the end
of the first round
well that's going to be their call right
because it's big you know we have a
great relationship where we we all you
know we sit in rooms and pretty much we
talk basketball everyday without love
and we sit around we go give our
opinions and you know when it comes to
coaching they've told me you know this
is where we're gonna throw suggestions
at you but that's your team whatever you
feel is best that's what we want you
doing and it's going to be the same way
with the draft pick I'm gonna sit in a
room on the tilt Robin magics who I like
the type of players I want to coach and
they're got you know they're going to
take that into consideration and it's a
two minutes left on the clock and and
they think you know I want somebody and
they want somebody else that's their job
is to make that draft pick so there's
you know there's not going to be any any
argument about it after the hand once we
take whoever we take and we're all on
board with it and that's what we're
moving so just like the coaching
decisions the final decisions are is all
me and what how I feel is best for the
team when it comes to drafting it's
going to be the final say will be be
theirs and what they think is best for
the team have you bought a pair of
tennis shoes that cost four hundred
ninety five dollars I don't think I've
ever bought any shoes that cost four
hundred ninety five dollars you ever
members I was raised by hippies so you
know we enclose and choose it was it was
whatever whatever the NBA was given my
dad for free that's what we wore growing
up so you haven't bought the big baller
bringe
tennis shoes is what I'm getting at look
no I know what you're getting okay all
right okay I I wasn't sure I was I was
playing though oh no I have not IIIi was
uh I have not bought those I still I
Kobe Bryant still nice enough Nikko
Nikko at Nike is his guy up there still
nice enough to to send me down the Kobe
Bryant so those are what I wear when I'm
on the basketball court why is it assume
that you'll draft long table
well obviously the he's from LA he you
know he's went to UCLA and he's an
unbelievable player I'm not absolutely
love his game the way he passes the way
he you know you know he makes everybody
on his team better it's an unbelievable
skill it's a joy watching him play I
think that's just a you know right now
on paper a great fit but the reality is
there is a lot of really really talented
kids in this draft and our scouts are
evaluating every one of them they're
putting together film edits for you know
for me and I'm watching my part and
we're gonna dive into what you know what
they're like we're going to call their
schools and see how they treated the
managers on the team and we're going to
call the trainer's and see you know what
were they were they good when they came
to the training room when they needed to
get healthy everything about them when
it you tomographic says hi there's gonna
be a lot of research done going into it
so that that'll play into into who we
draft as well but would you ask somebody
about levar balls involvement at UCLA in
regards to Lonzo ball would you ask
Steve Alford about them I wouldn't
personally but yet somebody in our
organization will absolutely what just
seems like you're taking the right steps
with this of asking the people behind
the scenes and I don't know if that
concerns you at all with levar Balls
involvement is that a topic of
discussion um not yet it when we get
closer to the you know to the to the
draft I'm sure we'll have all the and we
know we'll get a packet of information
on every player that we're really
interested in and then we'll sit down
and discuss it all but right now I'm not
I'm not concerned at all he I'm mostly
concerned with what what player can help
us win more than 26 games the most
before I let you go if I had a dunk
contest for coaches NBA head coaches yep
who's winning
oh hello how many fans are gonna get on
this damn no no we will well I I can I
can still dunk but I'm I have to get
properly warmed and stretched and it's
gonna it's not there's not gonna be much
behind I'm thinking I'm not sure how to
tell my head is and he codes can how
many coaches can even still dunk the
ball what about Jake kid I mean he's the
only other one think I don't eat the
other young coaches helping Brad Stevens
is dunking I'll dig Earl Watson is
dunking I bet J kid could still get up
he looks like he's in pretty good shape
but I'll probably come down to stamina
between the two of us tired first I
don't know I think Thibodeau can get up
I think he's got some mad hops - of all
evil alone absolutely hey great to talk
to you as always and good luck here over
the next month yeah thanks for having me
off all right that's Luke Walton hung in
there with something whose questions
Continental Tire Coach's Corner Seton
it's a Continental Tire Coach's Corner
thanks Dan yep through a proud exclusive
tire the Dan Patrick show and no matter
where you drive or what you drive
Continental designs tires from what you
do for more information visit
Continental Tire dot-com Continental
Tire seating for what you do the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience